cela fait 4 milliards d'années que
l'homme évolution la terre au fil des
âges il a su développer sa forme et ses
acquis jusqu'à frôlé l'excellence
technique chimie
indoor et will influence e stéphanie
bateau et ses 300 mille abonnés sur un
stade qui pouvaient déjà l'apprécier
chercher des pièces de monnaie dans son
canap prend des cours de piano bande est
donc ses flatulences pour le plus grand
bonheur de certains fans
mais à force de longer tout et n'importe
pas pour améliorer ces gaz stéphanie a
fini à l'hôpital après cet échec
l'influencé s'est reconverti dans un
tout autre business qui va peut-être
rassurer ceux qui n'avaient plus foi en
l'humanité and that she sound soit et
c'est donc grâce à ce petit écouvillon
qu'elle arrive à récolter la
transpiration de ses cendres eh ben on
n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
c'est fou ça elle dit qu'elle gagne 50
mille dollars par semaine en vendant sa
et ses pétages une seconde 500 dollars
pour acheter ça et ça envoie un message
terrible aux jeunes parce qu'il ya plein
de jeunes qui prennent ça au premier
degré qui se bat mois plus tôt cry dans
une entreprise normale et gagner 1500
euros je vais vendre mais psg vent de
l'aude mais ça gagne 500 $ et c'est
extrêmement dangereuse qu'elle fait même
si c'est sur le ton de la rigolade tout
ça très dangereux qu'elle a rien vendu
du tout d'y
accéder bien sûr tu sais comment quand
et annonce un chiffre c'est toujours en
dessous qui discutaient 400 milles c'est
pas vrai du tout sort de vantardise
comme ça mais
heureux avec le code de la sexualisation
du corps atteint voilà une femme peut
gagner sa vie autrement qu'en vendant
quelque chose qui est lié à ses
attributs sexuels etc moi je moi je
trouve moi franchement après moi je
ils font ce qu'ils veulent non je suis
désolé j'en ai marre de dire oui les
exemples écoutez moi bien arrêté des
comptes pour les acheter mais oui
exactement mais c'est vrai les gens ne
croyaient pas que les gens sont bêtes a
atteint désormais sous la menace non pas
du tout d'ailleurs voilà je pense
qu'elles n'ont pas de répéter d'ailleurs
mais oui elle en vend pas du lycée à
lormont bonheur du buzz et que le buzz
est que voilà en fait en faisant ça à la
craie dubosc il ya eu des it hurts qui
ont des bas c'est dégueu latin et du
coup elle a fait un buzz messier après
pas qu'elle en vaudrait à la fia qui a
par exemple un étron qu'ils ont à
plusieurs milliards $ en cryogénie c'est
la fois un rationnel de la centrale je
pense que ce serait pas une certaine dit
certaine manière une ont une autre façon
d'un vrai de la raison tant pour un
dollar après un pic à l'art et à la roja
n'a pas tort kenny moi je pense qu'il ya
assez de d' arnaque sur lesquels on doit
se pencher dans ce milieu là que nature
voir une fille qui te dit réellement ce
qu'elle te vend elle tenant son père
elle te ment sa sueur s'il ya des
crétins pour acheter ce truc là le des
fétichistes chelou bah pourquoi pas
parce qu'au final elle ne ment pas sur
la marchandise donc moi je pense qu'on
devrait plus bouger sur dans certaines
arnaques et ont généré monette et bien
sûr qu'elle mais bon parce que là où je
vous rejoint pas je sais que bâle - 90%
vous avez envie de me rejoint et là
encore vous avez raison mais je vais
dire une bêtise mais là où c'est
embêtant c'est que cette fille est en
train de mourir une vote plus que pour
exister pour faire du buzz ou pour
exister quelque part il faut faire
quelque chose de négatif et dans cette
société tout l'original
quoi on voit jamais tout d'un coup un
buzz super sympa d'une fille mais prise
et tout ça c'est fait n'importe quoi
la mère fait une bêtise frappe quelqu'un
et puis tu vas la concurrence à celle
place vendôme on crie tous au gym
s'est pas négatif mathieu away soit
négatif c'est tout c'est aussi le
fantasme de certains et c'est très bien
s'ils ont les moyens qui se paye un
fantasme comme ça plutôt de l'exercer
eux de manière négative là c'est gagnant
pour elle c'est gagnant pour les gens
qui achètent si l'on nous envie c'est un
commerce droit maintenant
vous dites elles n'en vend pas comme
elle désolée elle a montré ces chiffres
elle en vend dix par jour
à raison par la croix tu crois pas
facile mais on est à la limite de la
prostitution il va signer à la main de
jeunes femmes que le seul moyen de
gagner beaucoup d'argent c'est de vendre
leur corps d'une manière détournée alors
le sait qui commande ça c'est que des
pervers qui ont des fantasmes
dégueulasse et cette jeune femme si on
lui donne 500 euros pour acheter cp ou
l'autre c'est sain si on lui demande
plus d'argent ça veut dire qu en plus
méritoire plus dégueulasse plus de
limites à double tranchant alors ça veut
dire que les femmes qui posent nus pour
des grands artistes des peintres est en
train de dire qu'elles vendent leur
corps
fondre je suis dit ils arrivent ils
avaient ravi d'être ici pour un certain
prix c'est ça après forcément il ya plus
de limites pour 5000 de plus belle dans
son père mais non mais non il a raison
alors ça vient de là
généralement oui mais là où guillaume à
raison effectivement c'est que
évidemment cette stéphanie là elle peut
éventuellement on gagner un petit peu
d'argent et tout ça elle est peut-être
structurée elle sait se donner des
limites mais peut-être qu'il ya une
petite gamine qui disent ah ouais alors
elle en vendant cp et la transpiration
entre ses seins elle a gagné 10000 20000
mais alors moi qu'est-ce que je peux
faire en fait c'est ont créé des
monstres déjà magnétique qui était venu
ici et qui doit nommer 1900 les réseaux
sociaux crise est plus grave non mais
c'est bien sûr que c'est plus grave mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que comme on
crée du buzz et ont vite ce besoin qu'on
le buzz il va s'épuiser elle va dire ben
finalement il va falloir que je peux je
vends mon papier mon caca parce que ça
ira toujours plus loin en fait la wii et
c'est juste à la limite et les renom
pour les jeux la jeunesse sans soir
bonsoir
jet en thaïlande
[Rires]